what is up guys my name is Jonah and
welcome to episode 12 of 3d game
programming in Java okay I'm gonna be
frank with you guys I am freaking tired
today I I spent the whole day filming
like a little trailer thing in the ruins
of Melbourne City so it was fun but I'm
tired
it's like 7:30 I'm supposed to have a
toilet too so let's have the next
episode out in like an hour um and
that's not going to happen basically
since I'm only recording it now anyway
sure you get the gist of all this and
we're just going to jump right into it
and AH we're gonna do one under control
today because because you guys wanted to
do controls mmm I was your friend um
okay sorry yeah you can just pretty much
I'm not gonna read through all these
like I did last time stupid okay
anyway pointers we're doing we're doing
controls because I was the more higher
rated one anyway I'm just going to jump
right into it right now okay so we've
got this little thing here just okay and
we actually added some rotation first
thing I'm actually going to do real
quick is just clear all these values um
where is our rotation here it is so I
set that to zero so that we're not
actually getting anything just so we can
basically say this okay so what we're
going to do today is add functionality
where we press W key we're actually
going to advance forward we press the S
key we're going to go backwards a key is
going to go right left sorry and D is
going to go right and that's pretty much
it okay so let's get run on right on
into this so I want to go to display the
Java display class and basically all I
want to do here is sort of create a few
sort of classes and all that stuff so
we're going to create our own an input
handle class and I want to call it input
Handler and click create an instance of
it input
Handler and for this class I'll just
call it input because we need to create
an object of it and let's just go
oh well my credit yeah yeah all credit
right now and I'm actually just going to
make a package here called input and
we're just going to pop it right in
right into that package and we'll get
back to this later on okay and let's
come back let's come down into here why
am i working like this what am i doing
okay full screen and I'm just going to
go ahead and say input is going to equal
new input Handler and we're going to add
a few add a few functionalities here
want to add a key listener which is
going to go from input we're going to
add a mouse listener and I promise we'll
get into Mouse stuff later on because
it's not that easy to add and we're just
going to add key stuff now and a mouse
motion listener and I think we might
need a focus list
what am i doing less than that well
we'll need a focus listener because
every time we actually I'll show you
guys what happens but I want to add it
just for now because I'm gonna try and
make this tutorial as short as possible
even else probably inevitably going to
end up being like 20 minutes long anyway
so I'm just going to use Eclipse
basically to arm set our input handle
class to implement this okay and that
will automatically import us and input
our thing and we could just go ahead and
go focus listener whilst we have Mouse
listener but you know we're going to
have to manually import this stuff and
that can be a pain so and we have to
type it out so why not let eclipse do
that for us by simply telling it to
implement it by itself and we'll get an
error here because we've again it's kind
of the same thing here where we
implement runnable so we need to have a
run clot a run method it's the same
thing here you know we need the
appropriate methods for all this so
easiest way to do this is just add on
implemented methods and look at that
well how much stuff it just added
fantastic okay now the ones that
interest interest us the most at this
point is just key released key press and
focus lost but not so much focus lost
more key pressing key released as you
can imagine okay
so key pressed all we're going to do
here is say okay let's actually create a
bullying right now right here right now
we'll make it public and this will be
sort of like our key idea my called key
and we're going to set it equal to new
bullying and when I type six eight eight
three six okay make sure you gotta be
down that number is very important and
let's go ahead and go down into key
pressed and what we're going to do here
is when actually create an integer
there's two ways of doing this but I
really want to create an integer because
I think it's better and just basically
be our key code and when I set it equal
to okay it's changes to eight and
actually let's just find that and
replace it with a awesome okay so I'll
just hit ctrl off their final place um
and it replaces all of our things to eat
because that's a lot easier than our
zero argument zero okay so our key code
integer it's going to equal you know the
key event are dot get key code where is
this get key code and all we all we want
to do here is say that if key code is
split as greater than zero and key code
is less than k dot length which is
referring to our array that we created
then K is going to get the key code
array and we're going to say that's true
so basically if keep right if key if if
you press a key on your keyboard you
want to make sure that the computer
understands that you've pressed that key
so key press equals true if you press
the candy keyboard it sounds logical but
you got to go to define these things and
what's not going to do the same thing
here and we're just going to go ahead
and say for
and we'll make a full loop for this um
so we're going to go ahead and say that
if I you know when I is I guess when I
is less than K calls length or until it
is anyway because it's a full loop then
simply ah grab the I and let's set it to
false so key press set key press the
true key release set key press to false
easy
and the focus lost will be what we will
deal with later because I want to want
to show you guys what happens if we
don't sort of deal with folks lost let's
go ahead and go to okay we need to
create a few more classes let's go to
game first of all um and quickly create
a constructor for it and all that's
going to be is we are we need to create
another class but we'll do that in a
minute
first thing I want to do is I want to
define a few bullying's and this these
balloons are basically going to just be
the different sort of key events I guess
so we need to fill that out and I'll
explain what it is in a minute okay so
if this tutorial seems kind of rushed
but it is quite right quite frankly this
stuff's really simple arm
really really simple okay so basically
all we're doing here and we need to
obviously actually you know import that
Kay and actually while we're at it let's
just go down here or is it and um
and all we need to do there is Hotel
thing called input is type input dot
okay and that is it okay because we
added of course we added to here which
is why we need to to fix it up
okay so quickly going to explain I'm
just going to copy and paste it a bunch
of times because I don't want to can't
be bothered retyping it every time so
okay let's just I'm just gonna explain
this right now basically the reason
we're useable okay so what what we're
sort of setting here is is basically
keys so we use this VK w VK underscore W
means the W key on your keyboard similar
however want to go back we want to use s
key so we had s this stuff is really
simple you should just be able to you
know get it it'll in a logical fashion
because it's pretty logical okay and
basically what we're doing here is we're
going to say we we want to sort of
initialize these keys as a boolean and
the reason we're using a boolean here is
because you know the W key can be in two
in two stances as my phone vibrating
Facebook get out here according a
tutorial
okay so because the because the W key on
our keyboard can only be in two possible
I guess uh stances it can only be
pressed or released so that's why we see
bullying we use a balloon so basically
if the bullying equals true then it's
got then the keys pressed and when the
keys released or not pressed basically
is going to equal false and we want to
do this for everything so left right and
we'll just quickly do a turn left turn
left up
and turn right again will add stuff like
jump and stuff later this is just
supposed to be really like I really
don't want to add that stuff like later
on I just want to basically initialize
make sure that our our input handler
class is all working and all that stuff
will add stuff like jumping and
especially sort of you know
mouse mouse stuff and ah and all that
good stuff later on don't worry okay so
left is a right is D and I'm just going
to set left to equal little left arrow
nocked keyboard okay and we'll we'll do
up and down a bit later on because
that's a bit trickier okay so we've got
all this stuff and I know it's time to
create that new class so right over here
in input I'm going to create a new class
called controller and this is basically
I don't know I just called a controller
and that's just basically going to be
our I guess our player controls you know
basically our our class is going to deal
with controlling okay so let's make a
few um if you doubles here by the way
instead of um instead of creating like a
double and setting it equal to something
so like it's zero whatever and then
having to do another thing on a little
line we can actually do it on the first
line if we separate them by commas and
then we can define them later because we
don't we'll need to define them at the
moment
okay so X also maybe needs said so X is
basically our hot sort of horizontal
movement our left and right movement set
is our forward and back movement again I
have one for y that's when when we're
going to deal with jumping and all that
stuff we'll don't worry we will include
jumping of course jumping is very
important in games rotation and I'm also
sort of going to create like a sub thing
for that I'm going to call it X a is
that a and rotation a and the reason I'm
calling it rotation a set a and X a is
just you know because if you've already
used X but you want created again you
just go to the next letter in that case
a if I if I wanted to make another it's
sort of like against instance instance
of X I'd use B then C then D etc etc so
yet they don't really mean anything I
just need to have another variable
available to me and let's create a tick
forward and I'm one
basically incorporate all these
different arm and I'll paste in that
stuff letter left what else we have
right
turn turn left turn right I'm recording
this tutorial right just checking 30
minutes okay fine
Jenna left right do it think so yeah
okay and I was going to hack go ahead
and copy bullying in front of all these
because that's the way the cookie
crumbles yeah you gotta have bullying in
front of all of them and again if you
even if you hold down control and you
click it's not going to go anywhere
because this stuff is still in here like
this stuff is set on the spot but we
actually want to set all of these equal
to all of these and the way we do that
is really simple we just go control K
let me actually create the object first
should we do it private a little public
public public controller control
controls and let's import this this
should be okay the LS nominal input
doing and let's just take the controls
and say controls dot tick and here are
all our classes and that's actually done
it did it automatically which is
fantastic so again we're setting all of
these we're setting this control we're
setting all of these equal to these
there's our case not only our case this
case these keyboard case awesome okay
let's let's get right back into this
control stuff okay so I want to sort of
make a few a few doubles but we'll make
it them make a few variables basically
we want one for rotation speed and wanna
set that equal to I don't know one I
have no idea by the way I'm just I'm
just doing this up to top my head I
don't know if this will be good not
that's the awesomeness of testing you
know what be able to test this up later
actually we're just going to make them
doubles because I have a feeling that
this stuff is going to be way too fast
again we'll say
and I also want to make a move you know
an X movement basically walking forward
and back I mean sorry walking left and
right
also that equal to zero for now and one
foot moving forward and backwards called
said move could call it movement that
would be more grammatically correct that
night okay so basically 40 calls through
so if we've requested to move forward
then let's go ahead and increase the Zed
move right and this is this is all about
logic and talking about logic I've just
put an S there which is not logical
which is why I remove the S because it's
not correct just quickly here I'm
touching this so basically if we if we
press the W key if forward equals true
then basically if we request to move
forward then add 1 to Z sort of every
time it's pressed it's hard to explain
that's actually not really not actually
that out of slant
I hope I'm explaining it in a in a
logical fashion I seem to be using that
word a lot this tutorials probably got
really tired arm fatigue is the correct
word but yeah that move where we want to
move forward if we press the W key and
again we need to do the exact same thing
and I'm going to be lazing copy and
paste all this and if we want to move
back now say it with me guys what do we
want to do if we want to move back to
that booth can't actually hear you say
that because this is in live but we want
to subtract one from ZDF simple left and
right is honestly just about the same
but with X move so I not sure I think
okay let's just keep it like this we'll
see if that's I don't think that's
correct I think a sale way around anyway
we'll figure it out so yeah basically
we're doing the same thing but with X
move down and turn left we'll do that in
a second because we actually need to use
some cosine sine and all that good stuff
okay a turn right okay and we'll we'll
figure that out in a minute
um okay so let's go ahead and set said X
sorry equal to
plus a equal to XA and same thing with
the Zed Zed a and let's do the road mmm
okay let's do this right now so XA plus
equals x group X move times math dot
cosine and we're going to use rotation
plus our said move times math dot sign
and again rotation and we're going to
multiply all of that by our walking
speed okay and we got to do the same
thing for that except change some of
these things like for example this thing
and this thing and this thing so again
this is sort of the same thing that we
did here or is it just this thing it
sort of like the same thing we did here
except a bit more I guess in depth but
it's pretty much the same as this stuff
okay I think none are we still gotta
handle rotation that way and XA and
today our alternative thing is multiply
that by I don't know about 0.1 0.1 and
rotation and rotation is going to plus
equal rotation a and rotation a is going
to multiply and equal I don't know 0.8
we'll see and well that should be a okay
and we haven't actually used rotation
speed for anything and I think that
right now and that will be multiplied
okay of course we use that in a minute
arm so if you turn left we want rotation
a basically and we want to be able to
plus equal our rotation speed so
whatever whatever we set our speed to
equal is going to be basically the speed
at which we rotate because it's going to
be affected by speed hope that's making
sense I'm probably just explaining stuff
that you guys probably already know or
can logically there's that word again
understand okay
rotation is plus cycle except this time
is going to minus cycle because we want
to rotate the opposite direction okay
just format this real quick it's a
little nice ah
is that it I think that's it um well
there's only one way to find out we can
test it okay let's go back into render
3d it's 20 minutes Ori this is actually
going to be the long tutorial so far so
I hope you're enjoying this um I only
make this once a week so you know okay
anyway so what we want to do here is
actually let's just add I forward
forward since wasn't it plus forward and
there's going to be plus right probably
call this you know Zed movement in that
X movement but we'll live like that for
now and instead of game door time we
want to use game dot what's called call
it controls I said it
yeah Gander controls and dot X Z because
X is left and right remember game dock
controls help me out here clips and X
okay so let's test this out hopefully we
won't crash and it crashed
okay so let's figure this out what's
going on here we go so our killers in
the failed that is odd try start again
and say okay so it's definitely pointing
to here and it's not saying what
exception is generating break point okay
let's check this out
um well as Kayla snah
hmm that's yeah it's weird and it's not
even telling me what I'm getting it's
just crashing two tires out oh I am NOT
pointer exception what's not pointing
get away what's now pointing controls of
course silly me
okay we didn't set up controls look so
controls equals new controller okay and
that should work
no that's not working
odd
well first of all actually what while
this is a mess this is a new incorrect
I get hang on a minute
well I'm tired okay we completely failed
here actually this is not the correct
code get key code and this should
actually be an F statement full of I'm
thinking of the focus one so what it was
it if our key code and squared it in
zero and our key code is less than K dot
length and set key key code equal to
false okay so that should be fine that's
not going to fix us there hmm
what's it this is still giving us a null
pointers oh that worked but so why is
this throwing us an error
what's up Eclipse what are you doing so
it's running properly and as you can see
our thing is half working that's odd
actually that's really weird
I'm just going to try and restart a
close real quick I just start eclipse
again where's eclipse here it is
did you do the first time we've had to
race on Eclipse sometimes it does this
what I'd and I will say hmm that's odd
that is odd
so this is running Keys released is not
working probably there when we press
Kay's release it crashes okey-dokey I'm
going to try and fix this as fast as I
can but I'm tired now so good luck with
this okay here's another bug greater
than zero oh there we go
fantastic so it works but not in debug
mode okay I have to fix that some other
time
okay so basically what do we got the
well we've got the basically just of
this forward and backwards work that's
forward that's backwards that's left
that's actually not left that's actually
right if you know I'm pressing left
because I was right about my assumption
that this was incorrect it should be
minus minus and this should be plus plus
well not equals equals plus plus and
there we go and our rotation is kind of
dodgy at this point Oh
trippy okay let's sort this out this is
gonna be my longest tutorial yet guys
and I'm sorry
mmm-hmm
okay let's um I think okay let's go
ahead and actually add the focus curtain
I just want to do this um so basically
what we're going to do is when as I get
let me just demonstrate to you what does
so freaking out this is really an it's
really bugging me get it bugging me if I
lose focus as you can see I just
switched while holding the a key it's
not actually going to stop and I'm going
to have to press the a key again for it
to stop but if we enter this code in
here so for int I equals 0 i it's less
than what is it KL length fantastic here
at length I plus plus and I'm going to
do it's really hard actually it's
beginning of summer here and it's really
well not really it's still what does it
spring but it's really hot it's like 27
degrees it's pretty hot and we're going
to just set key I equal to false so now
you'll see that if we stop it if we are
if we start and we lose focus
it's going to go and stop which is
important okay so that's pretty much all
I can think of the region rotation is
not working is because we didn't
actually add a rotation in here our game
controls dot rotation
fortunately doesn't debug oh wow ok
that's working that's a good thing
that's a good um that's a good news and
good news everyone
Futurama good news is working bad news
is is way too fast
slightly bad news concisely fixed first
of all let's just roll with this - well
like 0.5 okay this is really okay if
anyone knows why this is happening
please tell me because I do not at this
point probably Lim tidal probably fresh
head tomorrow morning I'll walk it out
but why is this happening
it's kind of bugging me okay I mean why
is this wise is not debugging correctly
how it is what well okay well that's
still a bit of a problem that it's
actually bringing me up like with this
thing and then I have to manually resume
it for it to actually work that's I
don't know why that's happening if
anyone knows please tell me because I do
not that's the first time I was saying
that honestly okay but you know this is
live this is supposed to include all
these frigging fails by me so I hope
you're enjoying it um okay let's come in
here
okay we're already in here oh man we can
change rotation speed too I don't know
something like 0.5 let's just have it
okay there's still way too fast is it
actually debugging properly no probably
not
just run it see if that changed it okay
looks like we got to go down even
further 0.025 yeah there we go that's
correct that's better that's better okay
unfortunately I'm pressing the right
arrow key and it's rotating left I'm
pressing the left I reckon is rotating
right that's turning right so that means
that again I've screwed this thing up
and it should be minus equals here and
it should be plus equals here and there
we go that's correct and as you can see
you know you can point in any direction
and it will walk into that direction and
it will continue walking I'm just
holding the W key here and all these
sort of work together awesomely and we
have achieved rotate now we've achieved
user input so I don't even know what
we've achieved we've achieved user input
and don't worry about running distance I
think I'll probably do that next time
we'll figure it out okay
so so that is the end of this tutorial
I'm it's like 8 o'clock actually you can
see the time right here it's 8 o 7 p.m.
and I'm probably gonna go to bed that's
how tired I am but you know big day
today and it was nice and we added user
input you know what more can you want
what more could you want
ok
so this leaves me with a choice for what
to do next
our next we could we could do jumping we
could do jumping we could do mouse
movement of the mouse movement and that
would be easy
it shouldn't be too hard we could do
jumping so like spacebar would make us
jump we could do a mouse movement what
we could do
render distance limit the limitation
limiter okay so that's three choices you
guys have and I'm going to not type them
on screen action I don't even know why I
consider that okay so our 31 minutes
this is such a record by like 10 minutes
okay I'm guessing by the end of this
series we'll have like two out it to our
tutorials so look forward to that
um now but all of you guys said that you
like the longer ones so I'm you know I'm
not considering cutting this down at all
okay so that's three options guys post
them on the channel please place on one
channel that's where I read them the
most so the channel and you can see that
you know here's post here it'll say
episode 13 and you can post your
basically what you want what you want me
to do next
out of jumping mouse movement or or the
render distance
limiter okay so that's it I hope you
enjoyed this tutorial please hit the
like button if you did for the longest
tutorial ever 32 minutes and I will see
you guys later goodbye
a good night
you